Hello Freak bitches.
When you come across people like that because you're in the criminal defense
attorney world and you have to represent these people,
do you,
do you try to think like is there a way to fix this guy?
I mean,
do you put that in your head or do you just go and try to win?
I try.
Well,
when I get,
when I would get them to do the apologies because one of the.
I mean the thing is like for a lot of these guys,
too many witnesses,
too much of a record.
It's coming down to this fucking apology,
right?
It's coming down to our plan for what we're going to do next and talking with
them and coming up with a reasonable plan about what they're going to do after
jail or what they could do instead of jail and addressing like why would they
they did something wrong.
Okay.
Why was it wrong?
Like I would go through with my clients a lot of the times if I wasn't sure that
they were getting it and I would be like,
okay,
so you're going to have to give an apology to the judge.
You're going to have to tell them that what you did is wrong.
You're going to have to tell him that you know that it was wrong and you're
gonna have to tell them,
you know why it was wrong.
So why is it wrong to hit your girlfriend?
Uh,
she doesn't want me to.
Well,
okay.
All right.
There's one,
uh,
when you hit your girlfriend,
what did the police have to do?
They have to show up and they have to arrest me.
Were you nice to them?
No.
Do you think they like that?
Do you think now it'd be the time to apologize for being a dick to them when
they were just doing their jobs?
Yeah.
Okay.
But now say it in a different way.
Say it in a nice way and then I made them say it in a nice light.
Then you have to really coach them through this.
And do you,
do you let them know,
like listen to your freedom may ride on whether or not you're believable?
Yep.
Most important performance.
I would tell them like,
you,
you're not going to lie up there.
Everything you say is going to be true.
We just need to make you fucking recognize you for just a couple minutes.
You got to recognize this situation because you can't lie out there.
They hear too many lies.
They don't like lies.
Just it's like George Michael and freedom,
like take a lie and make it true.
A lot of times I would ask quote George Michael,
yeah,
I did that song freedom.
Yeah.
It's a good song.
It is a good song,
right?
Yeah.
Good on you for Admin.
A lot of people that shy away from giving George Michael that prompts he
deserves.
But I would use like take these lies and make them true.
I would use that on my clients.
And he's saying that.
No,
I'm terrible.
So you can say it.
No,
I can't.
There we go.
Dude.
How about,
I was in this a goat cart thing with Jason Ellis and Dominick Cruz is there.
If you're competitive,
you raised some fucking goat carts.
I see Dominic Cruz in the corner hyping himself up dead.
Serious gun.
They don't want you to win.
They don't want you to win this.
He's talking to himself.
Oh my God.
I'm like,
oh,
doesn't love.
It was crazy playing for keeps.
When this guy picks him,
he goes,
the guy who works there,
it's like some costco fucking warehouse thing.
They set up.
He goes,
fucking crazy.
And I went,
I guess man,
that's why he's world champ.
I tell Dick Jokes and your work at Costco because we think this is a game he
doesn't like.
There's no good.
I'm on one second.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
They don't want you to win
this sort of,
you know,
masculinity.
So fragile managers socialized to be violent.
They're not just socialized to be fine.
You know,
this is a hormone thing.
Men just are more aggressive.
And if you.
I means for instance in colleges,
right?
If you,
if you tell a women that the worst thing that's ever going to happen to them is
somebody putting a hand on their,
on their leg and you call that sexual assault and you put that in the sexual
assault statistics and you know,
you tell women,
oh,
you can wear whatever you want and you can go out with 3:00 AM wearing a
miniskirt and no man has a right to look at you and you know,
you know,
no victim blaming all the rest of it.
You're telling women in fact that they can put themselves in danger and bad
things are going to happen to those women.
We do live in more civilized times,
but we also have to recognize that there is something,
there is something dark and dangerous about men and it is what creates.
It's what it is,
what has driven human civilization to the heights that it has arisen to.
But it is also why men for most of the prisons,
right?
The sublime geniuses and the knuckle dragging apes of our species are both male.
Right?
And that's.
And you can see that in a variety,
different things.
People don't take like you've very seriously,
but you can see,
for instance,
in Icu distribution,
one of the suggestions that might be the case,
you know,
sublime musical and artistic geniuses up in the very top end of the Iq scale
where women tend not to exist.
Likewise,
you know,
down in the knuckle draggers,
70 and 80 Iq,
women tend not to exist down there either.
Men are more variable than women in general.
Men are more complex I think than women in some ways.
And this,
you know,
this,
the idea that you can just sort of buzzfeed your way out of rape and
civilization is just insane.
Buzzfeed your way out,
you know,
if you,
if you just,
if you publish enough listicles.
Yeah.
About how masculinity is so fragile and white,
straight,
white men are,
are the root of all evil that that's somehow going to stop rape?
No,
in fact,
I think that's probably counterproductive.
I think that's probably going to be going to push some men too,
but you know,
boil over because they're sick of being lied to enlight about.
But the good news is rape has been going down for 30 years.
American college campuses are probably the safest place you could possibly be as
a,
as a young woman in America today,
despite what the left tells you,
the lies it tells you about.
Uh,
you know,
about all sorts of things we're in.
We're in a good place,
but the left won't say that or acknowledged victory because it will put them all
out of business.
Well,
I was out of,
I was out of that head chocolate.
I didn't have enough chance to send the kit in the mail and get it.
So I just went to the store.
I asked to,
can I just want prone.
I didn't want to spend the $94 for the way because I didn't want to hold all
that protein powder.
So I went through the one on Lankershim and he goes,
do you take the preworkout shit?
Like I don't take my,
I take the fucking quadriceps.
I didn't tell him that,
but I take the,
I take like half of the shroom tech,
right?
I don't to have a fucking audit.
They're going to take half of those fuckers tax,
sometimes you're in the middle of class and get gasping for air because so much
air is coming into you and my body can't take it.
It's too much fucking.
And sometimes like you're like,
fuck,
this is too much.
So I just went there one day the guy goes,
take this.
It's like a drink before the fucking,
uh,
before you work out again.
I had it in the bag and I drove and I get them.
I go,
let me just try.
I tried half of it.
I did the class,
but on the way home I had the wildest fucking hot.
I had to go home,
take a shower and jerk off in the fucking shower because the heart with real
mama wasn't on.
Nobody was around.
I mean it was fucking evil.
And even after I jerked off,
it stayed hot dog and the shower,
I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ,
I got to save this shit and drink it with Mama's around these things.
But then I got scared because after I jerked off,
like an hour later,
my Hartstein that haven't popped up yet.
Then I'll put the shit enough with this,
but I don't do anything.
Listen,
I've never been a proponent.
Is that the word?
Yes to fucking red bull because when I was shooting a movie once I was up all
night.
You don't blow man.
I fucking drank three of those red bulls when I fell asleep,
so I said,
fuck it.
That's nothing.
That shit,
that shit don't work.
I drank three of those red bulls.
There was no set so those things don't fucking work,
so I've never been really been any energy drink.
I grew up with energy drinks.
You'd expect me to like energy drinks.
I hate all that shit.
I don't believe it.
When I was a beginning comic,
I used to take no dollars to drive all night.
That stuff's nasty.
Just when I would drink it with mountain dew and smoke a joint.
You drive off.
Just look like that all night and then you pull over and take a nap and I would
take an opera at the car because it was the winter,
like in those days I had to drive.
I would have to do the late show as a feature and then drive back to boulder
overnight from Boise,
Idaho or wherever the fuck I was in billings,
Montana.
So I would drive all night to get there to pick up the baby in those days I'd
have to do whatever the fuck I had to do.
One Night Jamie,
I pulled the car over and it was freezing out and left the car running and I
fell asleep and when I woke up I thought I lost control of the car.
You have no idea what happens to your heart.
Oh my God.
When you fall asleep and then wake up and I had to have lights on and I saw the
snow and I was like,
oh,
and you grabbed the steering wheel.
You put the brake on.
Really?
I'm not even fucking moving.
Oh my God.
So those.
No dozes with mountain dew with all my boy.
There you go.